[Musik]
burgschauspielerin dürfte schneider
liest ausgewählte rus kommentare andreas
beschreibt dieses von gerichtlich
eingetriebenen zwangsbeiträgen fed
gezüchtete arschloch von möchtegern
komiker verhöhnt und verspottet mit
seinem abgelassenen dünnschiss
ausgerechnet die bürgerinnen und bürger
mit dessen finanzieller hilfe er sich so
fett fressen durfte voll zum kotzen
dieser möchtegern non-plus-ultra komiker
ja was denken sie denn wie fett das fett
gezüchtete arschloch welke denn wäre
wenn er nicht so viel dünnschiss ab
lassen würde
übrigens wenn sie mal genau hin wenn sie
das oli welke hat gerade bei burger king
die türen von innen abgeschlossen und er
kommt erst am dritten januar wieder
heraus alles
[Musik]